un ancien pré-retraite mais il veut
continuer à travailler rentre dans une
boutique bien gominée costume et il dit
bonjour monsieur l'homme je peux parler
au patron s'il vous plaît oui c'est moi
bonjour monsieur enchanté je m'appelle
Gérard Delmas numéro 1 des ventes en
France numéro en vendeur commercial je
vends tout ce que vous voulez sinon
monsieur on recherche pas de vendeur
monsieur s'il vous plaît je m'appelle
Gérard Delmas numéro 1 des vendeur en
France Laurent commercial je suis
meilleur pour moi bon bah ok il sort
important il dit voilà si vous arrivez à
vendre ça bravo la journée passe il
commence à vendre
cette journée il y a pas un truc qui a
été vendu le vendeur du bah alors
qu'est-ce qui se comment vous appelez
déjà Gérard Delmas numéro 2 des vendeur
en France je pensais que vous avez du
numéro 1 je fais énormément le numéro 1
celui qui t'a rendu cette merde
[Applaudissements]